parce que j'étais moi
des amis aujourd'hui on va parler de
cette application je me suis renseigné
mais mort parce que je ne comprenais pas
ce phénomène et ça m'énervait de tout
mon coeur vous avez fait et quitter la
vidéo en voyant faire un lip 5 comme on
appelle ça et c'est normal et la d re
fois que vous en aviez vu un c'était sûr
musicale et rappelez vous musical et on
en a bouffé la plus musicale et à
l'époque sur youtube c'était terrible
c'est l'appli sur laquelle les gens
chanter par dessus une musique ou un
extrait de the vault dur de quelque
chose mais avec tellement d'égocentrisme
que ça mais 100 % des gens mal à l'aise
rassurez vous musical il n'existe plus
c'est devenu tic tac à une entreprise
chinoise a racheté musicali et à
fusionner les communautés de musicalité
de type 2 au type stock étant le music
ally chinois finalement et ça a donné
mais qu un endroit où je sais pas
comment décrire cet endroit généralement
les gens s'amusent juste à à danser et à
chanter en se croyant cette idée sur
leur musique préférée il ya quelquefois
des trucs innovantes sont couleur garder
et drôle qui font un peu penser à vannes
mais le gros problème c'est la plupart
des utilisateurs de type top ont entre
10 et 15 ans et quant à entre 10 et 15
ans et taina plihon dit vas-y amuse toi
et fais des vidéos où tu te crois stylet
et ben tu fais des vidéos qui sont très
mal ésente parce que tu as entre 10 et
15 ans et que tu as pas d idée d'où il
ya qu'à voir nos premières vidéos à moi
ou à n'importe que le tube heures pour
comprendre que quand tu es jeune et le
contenu que tu fais c'est pas où mais
voilà faut pas leur en vouloir à ses
enfants qui s'amusent avec tik tok c'est
comme ça par contre il faut pas non plus
les humilier en faisant des vidéos sur
leur gueule en disant regardez comme ils
mettent mal à l'aise aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on va faire il ya plein de
problèmes avec tik tok notamment
santraine du harcèlement c'est entraîne
la sexualisation de deux filles mec très
très mineures mais y'a un truc un truc
positif est incroyable que j'ai vu faire
positif parfois sont un succès les
trolls mec les trolls ont rejoint tik
tok sur tik tok c'est comme sur youtube
ou ailleurs il ya des challenge qui ont
été créés et donc c'est faire un truc
défini sur une musique définitive par
exemple le spo qui challenge qui
consiste à se maquiller en mode je fais
peur et a chanté par dessus une musique
que je peux pas mettre sinon je vais
perdre la monétisation de la vidéo et ça
y'en a pas ok les ayants droit à la haye
en a marre il ya aussi un autre chanel
je sais plus le nom désolé ou en gros
c'est quelqu'un qui se confie un peu
pendant 12 secondes qui dit des trucs
des vérités sur elle même et qui ouvre
son coeur est en fait ce qui s'est passé
sur tic toc c'est que tu peux répondre
au poste de quelqu'un et quand tu
réponds au poste de quelqu'un les deux
vidéos s'affichent de cette manière là
et du coup les gens s'amusent à je sais
pas reproduire des danses de fornas en
réponse à quelqu'un qui était en train
de dire un truc hyper sincère et et ça
me tue des brefs regards dans tout ça en
images allez comprendre pourquoi ça me
fait rire où je veux en venir et je vous
expliquerai la vidéo
base de challenge que c'est bon vous
puissiez comprendre en quoi le troll est
drôle voilà que vous avez un background
alors c'est parti alors ça ça la musique
j'ai remplacement au montage par une
autre mais sachez que quand c'est cette
musique c'est un truc où normalement le
mec fait la première vidéo demande à
l'autre de reproduire sa danse et y en a
qui sont pas d'accord avec ça et qui
répondent en tas pour le téléphone où on
s'autorise à n'importe quoi comme ici le
mec préfère se flinguer dans les marches
plutôt que de reproduire la danse de ce
mec torse nu voilà c'est ça que je suis
un petit look c'est que c'est très très
très très très superficielle tout le
monde veut être trop beau monde va être
trop stylé et tout le monde va être une
star sur cette appli et du coup ça fait
un peu vomir quoi qu'on y passe du temps
à un mec qui sait répondu plein de fois
lui-même et qui a fait un truc style est
apparemment oui puisque tu peux répondre
à tes propres trucs voilà c'est normal
c'est synchro au beau gosse ya quand
même des mecs qui font des trucs premier
degré qui sont innovants et créatifs qu
il n'y a pas que des soudainement vrai
mes vidéos préférées sont celles où en
gros dans le premier encadré à quelqu'un
qui fait ça qui fait semblant d'être
attirés de l'autre côté et qui d'un
couac cet effet un bisou et envoie la
personne qui répond doit faire des
mouvements synchro pour croire que c'est
son bras qui attire l'autre bon là
j'arrive pas à le faire on va alors
voici une vidéo ce fameux challenge pour
vous voyez à quoi ça ressemble quand
c'est réussi moi je peux pas le faire
tout seul c'est trop compliqué
[Musique]
maintenant on va tomber sur quelques
dérivés qui me font beaucoup rire c'est
de l'humour noir attend sur les gens
c'est grave crise
[Musique]
bras c'est tellement s'excuse mairie
allait mais qu'ils osent tout ils ont
peur de rien c'est fou or l option de
pouvoir répondre à quelqu'un en vidéo
it's a maté de vidéos côte à côte c'est
génial c'est le bay street mais en vrai
c'est trop bien
un jeune homme de fucking des organes de
la rave l'asecna avancer les gamers qui
font ce truc là sur cette musique là et
il ya plein de gens qui le font et qui
sont pas du tout des gamer et ça se voit
sur la vidéo qui sont pas des gamer
parce qu'ils n'ont pas un casse de gamer
ou alors parce qu'ils ont dans les mains
qu'on vient de voir une manette qui
n'est pas la manette d'une console sur
laquelle des ovaires web comme cette
personne qui a mis une manette de nes
dans ses mains overweight n'est pas sur
nes du
ok j'ai compris je crois que la fille si
elle a une manette qui n'est ni mais
deux passes 4 ni de xbox alors que ben
oui je sais que sur ps4 xbox
elle a un casque beats sur les oreilles
et personne ne joue avec un casque beats
donc les mecs l'autre aux laitages
explique les trolls c'est incroyable
même temps des fois ça c'est dur à
comprendre avec notre rôle est du coup
en utilisant n'importe quoi comme
manette et n'importe quoi
c'est drôle et sans faute
oh c'est pas bien de tous les gens qui
prétendent
alors qu'ils ne le sont pas en plus ils
le sont ils ont déjà joué à kent dick
roche une fois c'est sûr qui s'est fait
trop d'une manière incroyable il ya des
gens qui savent qu'il ya des trucs qui
s'amusent à juste répondait dans ce
format à leurs vidéos et du coup ils se
moquent à nous envoyer deux gars qui me
répond par une danse hors night c'est
impossible c'est une pauvre merde et
lille a sorti la carte sens inverse ou
non l'une des armes les plus fortes que
l'humanité créé mais kyle adore ça les
trolls de ce challenge là ça me tue on
va appeler ça le bisou challenge aller
parce que j'ai plus non la caisse qui
lui a répondu le rock puis 99% 7ème
envers les gens qui y pour le challenge
tik tok qu'elle over and hutch allen
s'est désolé je dois tout vous expliquer
mais je veux vraiment que l'on ne
comprenne bien les trolls si t'as pas la
rêve c'est pas drôle et même pour moi
quand j'ai vu ces trucs là au début ce
n'était pas drôle que j'avais pas les
réflexes un challenge où en gros tu mets
une image tu claque des doigts et le
truc avait sur images tu l'as dans la
main et donc à plein de gens qui
seraient mises à trembler face à ça au
plus dit elle est là elle tic tac
là les oreo les chips et le mec avec qui
il a demandé à voir
ah ce bon c'est vraiment après cette
vidéo que c'est la fin de ma carrière
c'est celle là a alors ça j'essaie
d'avoir ce que c'est en gros tous les
temps tu tapes compte à cames est ta
paire de chaussures change
[Musique]
c'est drôle et innovant c'est bien
c'est drôle je connaissais pas sous la
halle avec son rôle
[Musique]
les furies ce des gens qui je crois
qu'ils s'amusent à se déguiser en
animaux en gros comme ça en animaux
mignons sur tik tok et qui danse et un
frère de gens qui détestent ça et qui
répondent comme ça moi tout ça cool que
serra sont des gens qui aiment la même
chose à nos fameux challenge j'adore ça
[Musique]
c'est vrai que les gens pour des
parodies un challenge à deux comme ça je
trouve ça marrant il crée vraiment des
histoires avec ça c'est drôle
[Musique]
non
c'est horrible challenge où les
personnes qui n'aiment pas leur corps le
montre justement et ses deux petits
coups ils répondent en ce moment comme
des gros fils d'opta voyez là s'il vrai
darkseid de tik tok la tique qu'on va
moi j'en retire et les oreilles à cela
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les deux on en a marre du challenge mais
il se trouve à le faire malgré lui ses
géniales ça c'est la bonne utilisation
des tic toc
cette fois là et à l'école question
c'est bien fait là quelle est la base
[Musique]
sur gaza
au dessus de la ceinture ça compte pas
aller hop ça dégage mais arrêtez de
prendre tik tok au sérieux tik tok ce
n'est pas la vraie vie calme et vous si
vous créez du contenu sur internet vous
vous exposez à des critiques c'est
normal on s'est tous fait critiquer sur
youtube on a tous pris cher à mes
moments sur internet c'est comme ça il
faut prendre du recul [ __ ] les gens
ils prennent trop au sérieux les réseaux
sociaux ça par exemple c'est horrible ça
me fait plus tard c'est fou mais c'est
bien au moins on voit les trucs qui sont
horribles sas attaque physiquement à un
livre donc ça me faisait raurich c'est
pas drôle du tout au contraire la le
courage de montrer à son acné qui doit
la faire souffrir et se bataillent
réponse à ça ça me fait zéro rire pas
drôle
[Musique]
sam abrutis sam abrutis une heure de tik
tok qui j'ai devient d'abrutis
de fait
olé
[Musique]
il faut arrêter les gars de faire
semblant de se blesser ou de décéder
face à un contenu qui ne vous plaît pas
ok ça ne vous plaît pas mais ça plaît à
des gens mais ce serait drôle continuer
quand même impossible enfin pas trop
nombreux les mecs relig radical compte
qu'ils aiment pas c'est incroyable
[Musique]
maintien
enfin
je vais m'inscrire un peu je vais
m'inscrire 200 drôle de mot qui ont
changé novilladas l'arrêt je veux dire
ça un peu ça sera mieux que l'année sur
tik tok bolos le destin bon les amis
allez on arrête de s'abrutir j'espère
que ça vous a plu
écoutez tik tok prend tellement une
ampleur de dengue à 700 millions
d'utilisateurs et maintenant j'ai
l'impression que c'est invisible
personnes utilisent autour de moi
personne ne sait ce que c'est c'est eh
je voulais pas ignorer ce que c'est en
fait alors que ça prend une ampleur
incroyable voulait pas être ignorant
vis-à-vis de ça donc je me suis
renseigné et franchement comme j'ai dit
à des trolls qui sont drôles ya bien
entendu beaucoup trop de méchanceté et
de harcèlement aussi sur l'appui et ça
c'est dommage c'est pas si clément il
aura laissé me en a un ou deux j'ai vu
passer si on a fait zéro rires oui
c'était vraiment trop vilain pour la
personne et cet été c'était très direct
donc c'est horrible et les trucs faut
prendre du second degré faut prendre du
recul de toute manière d'une manière
globale par rapport aux réseaux sociaux
en tout cas si vous allez sur tik tok
après cette vidéo et vous voyez des gens
qui font des trucs malesan il juste
ignorée mais ça sert à rien d'envoyer du
mal à ces gens là juste ignorons les et
si vous voyez une vidéo il ya un
potentiel de réponse qui va être drôle
bas répondait manière drôle sans blesser
la personne voilà jeu désolé je fais
toujours c'est moral un peu gaga et au
fric en fin de vidéo mais je trouve ça
important en fait on peut rire de pas
mal de choses mais blessé vraiment
gratuitement une personne sait c'est
qu'on quoi c'est un vrai impact ce qu'on
peut faire sur les réseaux sociaux on
peut blesser juste avec des mots ou des
actes tout con juste en épandant une
vidéo où c'est un peu trop direct ce
qu'on dit ça peut faire très très mal à
personne en face faisons gaffe à ça mais
en tout cas mais grosse bonne surprise
chaque année tout traître au churchill
cup grâce aux trolls et ça me fait
beaucoup rire
voilà peut-être une vidéo si les trolls
évoluent il ya des nouveaux codes des
nouveaux délires qui arrivent là comme
l'echange qu'on a vu la halle est en
tout cas il est temps d'y aller
et savez-vous ce que je veux faire en
passant cette forme là c'est 80 de plus
sur tik tok pièce
[Musique]